fiona ce label fait la consultant en
relations internationales spécialiste du
moyen orient
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france le retrait des forces étrangères
de libye c'est la solution selon vous
pour mettre un terme au conflit dans le
pays
je crois qu'on est face à une guerre qui
est extrêmement compliqué le retrait
s'est passé pas seulement là la solution
pour résoudre cette guerre une guerre à
complexer une guerre qui a passé de
certains intérêts par rapport à la
question du gaz au départ des différends
entre on va dire au gouvernement un
gouvernement officiel qui le
gouvernement de sa rage et un
gouvernement officieux qui est le clan
de deux hectares à une intervention de
plusieurs pays notamment la concurrence
où la rivalité sur le gaz entre l'italie
la france par la suite l'intervention
russe et l'intervention jobson négliger
le poids financier de certains pays
arabes notamment des pays du golfe qui
sont impliquées dans cette guerre et ont
compris le qatar et les émirats et
dernièrement la position égyptienne qui
a menacé de faire une intervention aux
militaires dans le dans la seine dans
last in delà de la libye je crois que ce
qui était déclaré hier au niveau de la
ligue arabe
ça va pas changer la donne complètement
parce que tout simplement un espace à
une institution qui a une autorité son
pouvoir la ligue arable ne peut rien
décider par rapport à la question de la
libye comme j'ai dit toute manière il ya
un différend entre les pays arabes mail
sur la question de la libye les pays les
plus concernés par ces questions qui
sont les pays du voisinage lui parle de
l'algérie la tunisie voire même le maroc
est en contact et un silence total par
rapport à que ce qui se passe dans la
seine delà de la libye et je crois que
les enjeux maintenance sont pas
seulement des enjeux économiques par
rapport à la question du gaz était en
jeu également sécuritaire la crainte de
créer des bases militaires turcs en
libye le trafic des migrants voir aussi
la question des terroristes et du
terrorisme qui menace l'union européenne
et c'est pour cela en fait on a vu que
la position française devient de plus en
plus intense dans les derniers dans les
derniers jours 1 face à cette politique
on va dire expansionniste ou
cette politique de la turquie qui veut
d'abord redorer le blason l empire
ottoman est également profité de
l'interrégion politiques et des intérêts
économiques en libye
qu'en est-il aussi de la possibilité
d'un de l'ouverture de pourparlers pour
mettre fin au conflit c'est ce que
réclame c'est ce qu'a réclamé la ligue
arabe hier je crois que ça va pas ça va
pas changer beaucoup de choses tant que
moi je crois qu'on pour la libye
l'acteur clé c'est les états unis on va
on va on va pas se mentir parce que les
états unis celle états unis qui ont mené
au départ la campagne
ont-ils été par la suite franco-anglaise
de contrebande à kadhafi en 2000 en 2011
et et face à ce qui se passe
actuellement en libye en dehors de la
russie
les autres pays sont des alliés de
l'inde et des états unis soit la turquie
qui était membre de l'otan la france
l'italie ou même les autres pays du
golfe est également l'egypte du fait que
l'egypte reçoit annuellement des
subventions des états unis après 3
milliards de dollars pour soutenir
l'armée l'armée égyptienne dans lequel
les états unis a fait à un repli à
partir de 2012 y avait des mots clés qui
était l'assassinât de l'ambassadeur
américain christopher hill a annoncé la
de bengazi et à lester le terral pour
d'autres alliés notamment la france et
l'italie le qatar et les émirats et je
crois qu'il y aura un gros tour des
états unis dans la scène politique de la
libye pour trouver une résolution
politique de cette de cette guerre est
également pour partager les intérêts
économiques et géostratégiques entre les
différents pays impliqués dans cette
guerre qui devient pas seulement une
guerre civile mystique single est ce
qu'on peut appeler une guerre par
proximus à dire un gain délégué de la
houlette des mini-sites y ait des
rebelles qui est qui qui ont eu ce
qu'ils sont et font la guerre en
contrepartie de de l'argent d'ailleurs
hier beaucoup de rapporter parole de
satam mercenaires de safa djihadistes
qui vient de partout on les met donc on
est face à ce qui a été aidé par al jean
yves le drian c'est à dire à certains
ces réalisations de la scène politique
on y est alors justement puisque vous
évoquez la position française en vaut
peut-être peut-être des relations entre
la france et la turquie concernant ce
dossier libyen elles sont au plus mal
est-ce que
selon vous et c'est ce que demande le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères est ce que cette à l'union
européenne de prendre aujourd'hui les
choses en main je crois qu'il y avait
déjà des critiques françaises envers la
turquie concernant l'application de la
turquie dans le champ religieux un
français concernant la question des
cures rappelle bien sûr ce qui était
passé dans les dernières années en série
je crois que ce qui se passe en libye
c'est vraiment la goutte qui a débordé
le vase c'est à dire la france voit
qu'il ya une menace sécuritaire
concernant la question des terrorismes
consomme le trafic des millions
également la volonté politique de la
turquie de créer un des bases militaires
dans la ville de certé dans la ville de
tarhouna ce qui peut vraiment menacé pas
seulement la france et l'union
européenne mais même les autres pays qui
sont est impliqué dans le cadre on va
dire de la francophonie dans la
géopolitique de la france je parle par
exemple des pays du maghreb ou même des
pays du sahel là on constate une
certaine insécurité
donc ce qui fait que le différend franco
un tueur je comprends parfaitement par
rapport à toutes ces par rapport à
toutes ces raisons mais maintenant il
faut attendre une position claire quant
aux prix des états unis pour bien savoir
est-ce que effectivement le temps pour
un vraiment trouver des solutions
adaptées ou bien on sera face à un
scénario très très compliqué un scénario
militaire avec des guerres de de proxy
pour les prochaines années
merci beaucoup une asbl fait là je
rappelle que vous êtes un consultant en
relations internationales spécialiste du
moyen-orient